one of the problems Ron DeSantis is
having is his personality and Trump
posted to truth social the other day
that uh that DeSantis needs a
personality transplant the problem with
Rhonda sanctimonious is that he needs a
personality transplant and those are not
yet available and he does and here is an
example clearly DeSantis has been
advised by someone I guess you've got to
be more bubbly or whatever
he sounds ridiculous and it so obviously
contrived he's like pretending to be
bubbly now Governor why aren't other
Republicans doing what you're doing in
Florida and I say they are doing it and
they say where I say they're doing it in
Iowa and in fact this whiny Voice by the
way is really tough I was here in March
and someone kind of took note and
they're like man look at all the stuffs
I was doing Iowa was like the Florida of
the Midwest wow a new bubbly DeSantis
with a new personality maybe that's
going to appeal to people